Speaker 1: OK, so we're going to move on from this
Trump having to testify under oath thing because
at the end of the day, we don't know what's going
to happen. And even if he does have to testify,
he'll probably just plead the fifth. But Donald
Trump was heavily triggered by the decision
made by a judge just as the weekend was
starting that in the. Civil investigation
into Donald Trump's organization, Trump.
Don Jr. and Ivanka have to testify
under oath, and they should do so within the next
three weeks. Trump's lawyers may appeal it. We
still don't know what's going to happen. Donald
Trump lost his mind over this, and this, to me,
reads like a sign of major, major panic. Statement
by Donald Trump and this is a mouthful. OK, I'm
going to try to deliver it to you as written. Here
we go. So Crooked Hillary Clinton, one of the most
corrupt politicians ever to run for president, can
break into the White House, my apartment buildings
I own and my campaign. In other words, she can
spy on a presidential candidate and ultimately the
president of the United States and the now totally
discredited fake news media does everything they
can not to talk about it. That's one sentence
riddled with about four different lies. Hillary
didn't break into the White House, didn't break
into Trump's apartment, didn't break into Trump's
buildings, and didn't break into his campaign. All
of this surging from a mischaracterization of a
report from John Durham using the term infiltrated
when Durham didn't actually use the term. So this
is all lies and this is the setup. And now Trump
goes on to the decision made about his testimony
quote. On the other hand, failed gubernatorial
candidate Letitia James can run for the Office
of AG on saying absolutely horrendous and false
things about Donald Trump, a man she doesn't
know and has never met. Go on to get elected and
then selectively prosecute him and his family.
After reviewing millions of pages of documents
over many years, they come up with the fringe
benefits case on a car, an apartment and on
grandchildren's education. Now remember, that is
not the only issue at play in that investigation.
A major issue at play is the misstatement of the
value of assets like buildings. A really,
really big deal. But also, yes, Trump seems
to be admitting that people who worked for him
did not pay taxes on fringe benefits, and that's
you can't do that. That's not allowed. OK.
Continuing, she is doing everything within their
corrupt discretion to interfere with my business
relationships and with the political process
with the rest of the case. Even Cy Vance, who
just left the DA's office without prosecuting
anything additional because there isn't anything
additional to prosecute. There is no case.
The targeting of a these are just sentence
fragments strung together in a febrile screed,
the targeting of a president of the United
States who got more votes while in office
than any president in Capital H. History by far
and is a person that the Capitol are radical left
Democrats don't want to run again, represents an
unconstitutional attack on our Capital C country,
and the people will not allow this travesty
of justice to happen what people want. What
are you talking about? It is a continuation of
the greatest capital W witch hunt in history. And
remember, I can't get a fair hearing in New York
because of the hatred of me by capital, J judges
and the judiciary. It is not possible. Folks,
this is this is full blown panic. This is full
blown panic at this point in time, and this guy
is absolutely losing it now. Later in the show,
we are going to get to the confirmation that,
yes, Trump took classified documents to his house
and would regularly flush them down his party.
It's been confirmed. OK, we're going to get to
that after the break. But this guy is in such
an escalated situation emotionally because of
what's going on that he's liable to do things we
can't even imagine over the next few weeks. This
guy will do everything he can to avoid being put
under oath and having to answer questions because
he also knows, yeah, I mean, listen, he'll plead
the fifth if that's where it comes to. He will,
and it'll be totally hypocritical, given his
previous comments that you plead the fifth if
you're guilty, which by the way, if you believe in
due process, law and order and the Constitution,
your silence can't be used against you. But
Trump has. He almost considers it axiomatic
that if you plead the fifth, you're guilty, which
is the opposite of what a guy who claims to be for
law and order should be saying. If you claim
to be for the Constitution due process and law
and order, you be saying no, no, no pleading,
pleading the fifth is not evidence of guilt.
Now, of course, colloquially all of us
can understand there are situations where
if you have nothing to hide, you would just show
up and answer questions. We we can understand
that that's a colloquialism that is a reality.
But this guy is going to do everything he can
to avoid being put in that situation to begin
with, and we will be following it all the way
down to the bottom after the break. It is now
confirmed the National Archives has confirmed
Trump took classified documents to his house.
It's been turned over to the Justice Department
and the Justice Department is investigating.
We'll take a quick break. Let me know your
thoughts about this story. Find us on Facebook
at Facebook dot com slash David Pakman show.